[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
our kelly's ex-girlfriend faces
cross-examination the horrifying
testimony about being forced to eat
feces as women were allegedly locked in
the singer's home they did not know a
world without r kelly in it because of
the limitations that he placed on them
and the former school resource officer
during the parkland shooting will have
to stand trial his attorney responding
as parents say the officer hid during
the massacre everything he did was meant
to save lives plus the man who was the
naked baby on nirvana's breakthrough
album is suing the band the now 30 year
old calling the cover image child
pornography and later i don't kill a lot
robert durst's 50th day on trial the
real estate air facing more rounds of
cross-examination by the prosecution
i'm in jail law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with day six of r
kelly's sex crimes trial r kelly's
former girlfriend identified only as
jane doe number five described years of
abuse now she's faced cross-examination
by kelly's defense
while jane doe five said on direct that
r kelly forced her to lie to others
about being with him the defense tried
to attack her credibility through the
letters she wrote in those letters jane
as she is not using her real name
defended r kelly and said that her
family was using her to get money from r
kelly and destroy his career jane read
letters to the jury that she wrote to
her family while she was living with r
kelly as one of his ex as one of his
girlfriends in one letter she accuses
her mother of telling kelly he needs to
send ten thousand dollars to a bank
account monthly for sleeping with her
daughter the defense tried to drive home
the idea that jane and her family were
using r kelly for his money but on
redirect jane told the jury that the
letters were r kelly's idea to protect
him in case of a trial like this one the
prosecution ended redirect with a fury
of questions about getting stds from
kelly being told to write false letters
being forced to have sex with other
females and a male and chastisement or
spankings all from r kelly
so why would a woman want to stay with r
kelly during the time of the alleged
abuse terry austin spoke with a clinical
psychologist to explain
dr catherine coleman told me r kelly
likely targeted his victims for a reason
finding vulnerable people to control
all of them were aspiring singers and so
they see r kelly as this you know really
the celebrity this guy who's really
started and was able to make aaliyah
into the the performer and celebrity uh
that she was
and there's this hope that he can do the
same thing for them and so that's
probably quite a bit of what keeps him
in this relationship of if i just stick
it out a little bit longer i can be
famous too exactly we saw that jane doe
number five she testified and she
actually said that he physically abused
her that she got cuts from being spanked
by him that she was made to urinate in a
cup and even eat feces that sort of
behavior is extreme
what would make someone continue even
after that sort of behavior
well you see you see this a lot in the
cycle of abuse whether it's with um
domestic violence um it is that there's
often times this uh you know we call it
this honeymoon or this princess period
that keeps people sticking around is
that they suffer abuse and then
afterwards the abuser
provides them with something he really
kept them isolated and he took care of
them financially and made sure that they
had shelter over their heads this really
restricts their freedom and their
ability to even think of a life without
him so this is going to keep them in
that cycle of abuse
joining us today is legal analyst dina
dahl and terry austin dina r kelly's
team is focusing on minor
inconsistencies rather than attacking
jane doe's more shocking allegations
like being forced to eat feces why do
you think that is
well the last thing they want to do is
remind the jury yet again about that
shocking allegation so instead they're
going to attract attack her credibility
by you know a thousand small pieces and
that could actually be very effective
you know if if they do convince the jury
that she was lying in all these other
instances then they're going to imply
that she's also a allying in this
shocking allegation
it's also possible they're
finished with the questioning
they may kind of go into that a little
bit more with that specific allegation
as well interesting now terry lacrosse
and redirect of jane doe 5 is going back
and forth on the truthfulness of these
letters written by jane the defense only
needs one juror could this have created
some doubt in jane's testimony
it may have brian but i don't think so
because
this letter is something that the
defense wants people to believe but why
would anyone write this unless they were
forced to write this it says that the
parents wanted to extort kelly and that
he
you know was seduced by them and that
they lied about their age why would
anybody write that down unless they were
forced to do it and if they were forced
to eat feces i think the jury would
really believe that they were forced to
write this type of letter which
apparently according to the testimony by
jane he made her write it for collateral
so i think there could be some doubt but
at the end of the day i think
the jury is going to believe jane yeah i
can understand the defense's argument to
some extent at least theoretically that
people have different types of sexual
encounters that they will and will not
allow but this kind of goes beyond the
usual that i think most people in the
jury will think yeah you chose to eat
feces and chose to do this abuse things
gonna be hard for the jury to come up
with the defense's response what they
want as a response but of course will
continue to follow it turning now to
more top legal news disgraced attorney
michael avenatti has scored a legal win
for now a judge declared a mistrial six
weeks into his embellishment case
avenatti is known for representing
stormy daniels and is currently serving
a two and a half year sentence for
attempting to extort nike for the past
six weeks avenatti was on trial for
allegedly stealing nearly 10 million
dollars in settlement funds from several
clients in this case avenatti served as
his own lead council he successfully
argued prosecutors failed to turn over
complete financial records a new trial
is now scheduled for october
now to the major leagues and the former
los angeles angels official now accused
of supplying drugs to mlb players
ex-public relations director eric k is
accused of distributing fentanyl which
investigators say led to the overdose
death of angel's pitcher tyler skaggs in
2019. kay is set to stand trial in
october for skagg's death now
prosecutors say they plan to present
testimony from five players who say they
too receive oxycodone from k k is
pleading not guilty
still ahead on law and crime daily why
the famous album cover from nirvana is
now the subject of a lawsuit but first
the parkland shooting we speak with the
attorney for the former school resource
officer his response to parents blaming
the officer for not going inside the
building next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back the attorney for the former
school resource officer accused of child
neglect in the parkland school shooting
is speaking out about the case law and
crimes angenette levy is here with the
interview of scott peterson's lawyer
brian scott peterson's lawyer had asked
that all of the charges filed against
him including child neglect and perjury
be dismissed he lost that request and
his attorney says he is innocent
what i learned he did
nothing wrong everything he did was
meant to save lives
and certainly he did nothing criminally
wrong attorney mark iglarsch on his
client former broward county school
resource officer scott peterson peterson
is accused of neglecting children by not
entering marjory stoneman douglas high
school in 2018 as nicholas cruz shot and
killed 17 people and wounded 17 others
you don't do justice for all these
people who died by doing an injustice
against my client peterson faces seven
counts of child neglect culpable
negligence and perjury
eiglarsh says peterson made decisions
based on the information he was
receiving in real time that day peterson
has been roundly criticized for not
going into the school iglarz says he
followed policy he takes a tactical
position of cover
and didn't know
until cruz was gone
where he had been and what he was doing
the second position is even if he did
know which he did not his policy at the
time makes it clear they may confront
the shooter it gave him that option he
could wait and call swat and contain but
he didn't know
the families of those killed feel
differently jamie guttenberg was killed
that day her father tweeted when
peterson was charged in 2019 you could
have saved some of the 17 you could have
saved my daughter
now mark iglarsch also argued that scott
peterson would not be considered a
caregiver under the child neglect
statute he says a caregiver is somebody
like a parent or a teacher's teacher but
prosecutors say that peterson would be
considered a caregiver he will be back
in court in december brian
thanks anjanet back to discuss the
latest in the parkland shooting saga is
legal analyst dina dahl and terry austin
terry why does it matter if peterson is
considered a caregiver or not and what
do you think he is under the law
as a caregiver brian there's a slightly
higher duty and i think it would make
the case a little bit easier to have him
classified as a caregiver but the point
is whether or not he's a caregiver he
still has a duty he was hired he was
paid to protect the school to protect
the students at that school and he
failed to do that and there is a
culpable negligence charge here and the
jury could easily find that he was
negligent so i think the decision to let
the jury decide and not dismiss these
charges makes complete sense under the
case law we could see a change in the
actual definition of caregiver if this
case goes in that direction
now dina whether or not there's a trial
there are charges at least and this case
could have huge implications for the
country when it comes to officers in
schools what do you think the correct
result here should be and should this be
a criminal or a civil matter
i think it's great that it's going in
front of a jury so that they can decide
these issues fact
i think there is enough under the law
let's see about like a doctor right so
if a doctor in a hospital doesn't give
care to a patient they can be liable for
that
neglect to do that i think that's very
similar you have certain jobs in this
country where when you take on that job
you take on a responsibility of care
so i think here it was good to have
brought this charge and maybe it makes
it clear if you're going to be taking on
this a role there is going to be some
sort of obligation put on you to carry
out your job yeah it's going to be
interesting to see how it plays out
because i could also see the argument
that this would have a chilling effect
on people wanting to take this job
because they have to throw their life on
the line uh but we'll see how it plays
out and jeanette what's next for
nicholas cruz's case
well his trial date has not been
scheduled yet and his lawyers have said
that he would plead guilty in exchange
for the death penalty being taken off
the table prosecutors have not agreed to
do that they want this case to go to a
jury and cruz is scheduled to be back in
court next week for hearings on several
motions all right so those are two
potential trials coming out of this this
school shooting we'll see how it plays
out of course give you updates as it
continues coming up on law on crime
daily durst's sixth day on
cross-examination his clap back to the
prosecutor plus an iconic album cover
and why the subject is suing the band 30
years later exclusive legal analysis
after the break
[Music]
we're back and it's not smelling much
like teen spirit for the famous nirvana
album never mind the man who was the
infant photographed on the cover is now
suing claiming the image is child
pornography
spencer eldon was four months old when
he was photographed for one of the most
iconic album covers of all time
nirvana's 1991 album never mind it was
widely interpreted that the album cover
depicting a naked baby in a pool
reaching out for a dollar bill on a fish
hook is an anti-capitalism statement
eldon however now has a different
interpretation the now 30 year old is
suing the remaining members of the ban
kirk cobain's estate and the record
company on grounds of child pornography
stating that his infant self portrays a
sex worker the lawsuit states that
defendants intentionally commercially
marketed spencer's child pornography and
leveraged the shocking nature of his
image to promote themselves and their
music at his expense
the now adult is known for recreating
the album cover with swim trunks on on
multiple occasions most recently on the
25th anniversary of the album's release
for the record we're not showing the
full picture there of the album cover
just so you know but let's bring back
legal analyst dina dahl and co-host
terry austin to make sense of his iconic
album cover terry is this a case about
child pornography that nirvana profited
from this cover and he did not or
something different altogether
brian this is one of the most bizarre
cases i have ever seen first of all
eldon took advantage of this cover photo
and it gave him fame and now all of a
sudden he's claiming that it's child
pornography and technically under the
definition you have to have some sort of
involvement or sexually explicit
something on the picture and that
doesn't exist here and i think the fact
that he has been using this should be
used against him and i think the case
should be dismissed altogether i think
to your point he's upset he hasn't
gotten paid and perhaps you know maybe
they should make some payment to him and
the fact that he's been using it all
this time means he's kind of giving
consent yeah i wouldn't be surprised if
we hear about a settlement on the side
in this case goes away
uh dina in the original cover you can
definitely see it all but does this fit
the definition of child pornography or
is it perhaps artwork
right and that's the thing one of the
exceptions to child pornography is that
there is a serious artistic merit and
you can hear this was on a music cover
that's actually been on it for such a
long time that if the public had had
some sort of reaction right usually
pornography kind of is based on how
people react to it we would have had an
outcry when this first came out so you
could argue very easily that this is
similar to
naked pictures of children that we see
in art museums all the time
it could also have some sort of a
contractual argument it's unclear
whether or not his parents clearly
consented to the nudity of this picture
and what he's asking for only 150
dollars per defendant seems so
reasonable that i imagine we're going to
have a settlement in this case and it
won't actually go to trial absolutely it
would be interesting to see the trial
but i agree with you dina that a
settlement is probably the closest thing
that we're going to see on the horizon
for this case thank you both when we
come back robert durst thinks kathy
might still be alive how the prosecutor
is fighting what he thinks are lies from
the accused murderer
[Music]
welcome back we're back in california
for the 50th day of robert durst's
murder trial and day six of robert durst
cross-examination
robert durst is testifying in his own
defense claiming that he did not murder
his best friend susan berman execution
style in december 2000 it is alleged
that susan had exclusive information
about robert durst's missing wife kathy
a murder that the real estate heir is
also accused of investigators say berman
placed a phone call pretending to be
durst's missing wife to call in sick to
her medical school rotation outside the
presence of the jury the judge gave his
opinion on the matter
i think there's overwhelming evidence
that susan berman
made made the call
and that
there's overwhelming evidence that susan
berman did make the call the question
here is
is the implication is that no one else
would have done it there is no one else
and so the the the what the people are
that people are entitled to present
their theory if there's any evidence to
support it
then when the juror was brought in
things got heated on the stand with
lewin and duras trying to get under each
other's skin this was met with
interesting remarks from the defendant
are you stalling for time right now is
that what this is about i'm just
scrolling for time i'm in jail overruled
he asked the witness if he's stalling
for time the witnesses let's assume
you're lying right now
let's assume i'm telling the truth right
now well that can be that can be a
hypothetical the defense gives you
that's not my hypothetical let's assume
you're lying right now with your heart
that's racing not mine would you then
john lewin caught durst in what could be
another slip up about what he thinks
really happened to kathy the prosecutor
brought it up again to the judge when
the jury was not in the courtroom
did not make up a story
about how cassie had died
to the best of my knowledge kathy is
still living i've accepted for a world
while that she must be dead
your explanation literally
60 seconds ago was i believe kathy durst
is still alive today so which is it as
you sit up here
there are so many lies coming out of
your mouth that you can't even keep
track
of what the actual lies are what the
lies that you've made on top of the lies
are and you're confused about everything
i am not confused
i told very few lies committed more
perjury than i've ever seen in my life i
believe the court would say he's never
seen this amount of perjury there's so
much perjury that when i'm impeaching
him about perjury he commits more
perjury i almost can't even keep track
of all the perjury
i can't keep track of how many times
john lewin says perjury but let's dive
in dina what do you make of judge
windham saying
there was overwhelming evidence that
berman made the call for kathy do you
agree or disagree
i think what he was saying was that the
prosecution could present that theory
and their questioning because they've
already
um introduced overwhelming evidence he
wasn't necessarily proving that that was
he wasn't necessarily saying that point
has been proved and i think he's
absolutely right there's been
overwhelming evidence presented i mean i
personally saw more than three hours of
a
student talk about how unlikely it would
have been for kathy to have made the
phone call to the dean of the school so
i think the judge is absolutely right
about that there is going to be a lot
for this jury to parse through including
the perjury perjury that um that
a prosecutor just mentioned there it's
gonna be very convoluted and and
that's what doris wants he wants to make
this kind of polluted absolutely more
confusion definitely helps the defense
terry in the latest episode of grumpy
old men i mean california versus robert
durst is durst doing himself any favors
getting under lewin's skin or is
this just who he is
brian listen this is definitely durst
being durst i hope though that through
all of this the jury is able to look at
this evidence and make a determination
based on the evidence and not make a
determination on who's doing the better
argument who's the nicer person who's
being mean
and you know ultimately
lewin looks much better when he sticks
to what the evidence is when he's more
controlled when he's not talking in
sarcastic terms i think the jury
appreciates that and wants him to be
more straightforward so kudos to him for
getting all this out but i think he
shouldn't let durst get under his skin
absolutely john lewin wants durst to
play his game rather than the other way
around dina terry thank you and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you